vous savez que le roi Charles III il
parle très bien phrase en revanche
Camilla pas beaucoup voir même pas du
tout alors Charlie lui a dit récemment
écoute que Camille a vraiment ça va pas
tu as des trop grosses lacunes je vais
te donner des leçons tous les jours que
tu vas apprendre en mot et se mot tu vas
devoir le reconstituer dans une phrase
commençons par ce Laye
je réfléchis une heure après elle
revient le soleil y était de sortir oh
parfait car il n'y a parfait on va
passer au stade supérieur un peu plus
compliqué mouton mouton faut que je
réfléchisse Charles s'en va Charles
revient tu écoutes ou Charles va me
compliquer mouton nous tombe
le soir à Clarens house cette fois et
bien à nouveau il
et au petit matin camille a dit Charles
j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé le mot ah bon
mais quoi quel est ce mot il est mou ton